la surveillance par l'État est
omniprésente en Chine les autorités
auront dorénavant encore plus pouvoir
en plus de la divulgation de secret
d'état l'acquisition de tout document
affectant la sécurité nationale et les
intérêts de l'État chinois sera
dorénavant illégal selon la nouvelle
version de la loi anti-espionnage les
autorités auront le pouvoir de fouiller
les appareils électroniques et autres
biens de suspects elles pourront même
les empêcher de quitter la Chine les
entreprises de télécommunications auront
de plus l'obligation d'assister le
travail des policiers en fournissant de
l'aide technique des expatriés chinois
et la classe d'affaires internationale
sont inquiets c'est normal pour toute
canadienne de se poser des questions
comment vais-je aller en Chine dans
manière sécuritaire je pense que on peut
pas se le cacher puis c'est un des
éléments qui fait en sorte qu'on a eu
tant de difficultés diplomatiques avec
ce pays-là depuis quelques années c'est
à la Chine de faire une démonstration de
de sérieux puis de droit de la personne
qui fera en sorte que les Canadiens se
sentent plus à l'aise
se resserrement de la loi en Chine et
d'autant plus préoccupant pour les
Canadiens après l'emprisonnement pour
espionnage pendant plus de 1000 jours
des deux Michaels spiver la chercheuse
et ex-conjointe de Michael covering
ne souhaite pas revenir sur les
événements bouleversants mais elle
affirme qu'elle n'est pas surprise par
ce tour de vie supplémentaire du
gouvernement chinois
la loi anti-espionnage chinoise romaniée
demeure vague et présente d'importants
risques pour les libertés fondamentales
selon Human Right Watch d'ailleurs des
responsables du renseignement américain
ainsi que le gouvernement taïwanais
mettent leur ressortissant en garde
contre les dangers supplémentaires de
voyager en Chine
ici Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada